And No,
good afternoon everyone,
it's a nice sunny Sunday afternoon,
so I decided to get out of my house,
get out of the apartment,
come outside in the sun to the partner,
my video here.
So today I want to talk about one of the
more popular or talked about language
programs or series of language programs
out there and it's called Michel Thomas.
I've used to have the Michel Thomas
Programs.
I've used Michelle Thomas French and
Michelle Thomas Arabic,
which is Egyptian Arabic by the way,
if you wanted to know.
Um,
and I'm just going to give my review,
my impression based on my experiences
with it.
Now for each of them.
I did the basic course,
the advanced course and the vocabulary
builder course.
I've done all three for both of those
languages.
The names are not really accurate.
I don't think any of the advanced ones
are really advanced.
I think it's more like introductory part
one,
introductory part two and more
introductory vocabulary.
That's what I would rename them to.
I'll get more into that later.
But basically Michelle Thomas is an
accelerated learning program and
accelerated learning style.
His,
his big thing,
Michelle Thomas,
his big thing is an absence of stress
when you're learning,
there should be no stress and no feeling
of responsibility for your own learning.
The responsibility for your learning
rests with the teachers so you're
supposed to feel very relaxed when
you're learning and that puts you in a
better state for learning efficient
route,
which is something I agree with.
I tried to use that in my teaching as
much as possible.
Try to make the students feel relaxed
and feel that there's no pressure upon
them to learn something.
They're not ready to learn all of that.
So that's part of his methodology is the
lack of the absence of stress in the
absence of responsibility and when he's
teaching,
he's kind of meditative.
Like you can hear on the cds when you
listen to it.
Mr Thomas himself,
he's,
he's very relaxed and I think he is
consciously meditating and that's
supposed to relax the listener and the
students.
So that's just something I noticed.
I can't guarantee that,
but that's what I feel when I listened
to it.
The guy himself is meditating when he's
teaching the course that's supposed to
transfer to you,
the listener.
So there's that part.
Another thing,
another element of the accelerated
learning is that he teaches the language
in an order where everything that's
taught is connected to what's taught
next.
Everything is a building block is
teaching you a small piece.
Then he teaches you another piece on top
of that and another piece,
and then you're building progressively
more difficult sentences as he does
that.
And the way he does it.
It's just very,
um,
it's,
it's just very easy to learn,
easy to learn each piece,
and he does a good job of connecting
them and explaining them and using some
mnemonics to help you remember in that
kind of thing.
It's also a very teacher centered
approach.
So the teacher is always directly
engaged with you and telling you what
sentence to produce.
So there's no free practice,
like basically current methodology of
language teaching is you,
you teach the language and then you have
some,
some exercises to practice the language
structures and after that there's some
kind of free practice.
Like somebody will ask you a question
and you have to respond freely from the
things you've learned without being
prompted,
without being reminded what to say,
so at some stage you are producing the
language freely,
but in the Michelle Thomas programs,
there's none of that.
It's all controlled practice,
which means that you're learning a lot
of structures kind of quickly,
but you're not given the opportunity to
produce them freely.
What I think of it is the way he set it
up as like a very sheltered environment
for learning that language.
If you're not supposed to do any
homework,
you're not supposed to use any other
materials.
You're only supposed to rely on him for
all of the learning.
So the positives of this accelerated
learning method are that you feel very
encouraged.
You feel very encouraged and motivated
because it's set up in a way that you
never feel that you're failing.
You always feel like you've succeeded.
You're not allowed to fail in the method
really.
And if you make a mistake,
he corrects you right on the spot and
you're supposed to fix it immediately.
So you always finish every moment of the
lesson feeling successful,
so that's kind of,
it's meant to encourage you and meant to
keep you in that ideal learning state,
which is good for what it is,
but it can be negative and in a way part
of the feeling of that,
the feeling constantly encouraged to
feeling nothing but success all the
time.
It makes people sometimes feel kind of
invincible and it makes them delude
themselves into thinking that they're
really good at the language when
actually they're still a really low
beginners.
So that's kind of part of the danger of
the Michelle Thomas method.
You can go online and you can read some
people's reviews of the method and you
look on Amazon.
Some people are saying,
wow,
I'm fluent after five hours and things
like that.
And you think,
no,
you're not.
Come on.
That's just a,
a kind of self delusion.
And I guess just people get,
what's the word?
Um,
it's kind of euphoria I would say from
just that feeling of success makes
people really excited.
And that's good if you are thinking of
it realistically,
if you know from the start,
okay,
this is an introductory course.
I don't expect to be fluent from this.
I know that's impossible.
If you have that realistic attitude in
mind,
then that sense of euphoria is good
because it motivates you to keep
studying and to to get some more
materials and keep going with it so it's
good.
Just don't fall into that trap of
thinking you know more than you do
because the danger of learning in that
really sheltered environment where you
feel nothing but success,
nothing but relaxed kind of confidence
with the language.
When you get outside of that into the
real world and you try to communicate
with a native speaker and you don't
understand anything and you can't
remember how to make a sentence and you
can't remember the vocabulary you
learned in that Michelle Thomas
sheltered box,
then you're going to feel discouraged,
right?
If you're not expecting that.
So that's.
That's like I mentioned before,
you don't get any experience interacting
in the Michelle Thomas Program.
You don't learn how to respond to
anything that is said unexpectedly.
You don't learn how to accomplish a
task.
You don't learn how to paraphrase or say
things you don't know how to say yet.
It's always just you say something.
You already know how to say.
You say exactly what the teacher tells
you to controlled for you to be able to
transfer that into conversations with
native speakers so it it's good for
getting one very basic thing down,
which is the sentence structure of the
language.
You get the sentence structure and basic
vocabulary so you can make sentences,
but the harder part of becoming
proficient in a language is interaction
and communication.
Unless you just want to type some
sentences,
unless you just want to write sentences
and you as an exercise,
then you need to interact.
So that's the part that's really the
challenge and it could cause a lot of
discouragement if you are not prepared
for that.
Just focusing on the Michelle Thomas
language style of learning.
Okay,
so with all that said,
I think Michel Thomas.